It's really neat to look at all my ancestry, maternal, paternal
lines. Even my possible Neanderthal connections. but if I actually had my
mom, my dad, my brother, sister, my cousins. If I had them
all participate in 23andMe, would I be able to see our interrelationships?
>> Yeah, it really shows up strongly in our
DNA, that's right. For instance, if we compare Leticia
to her mother, father, and brother, we can see
which segments of her chromosomes match with which parent.
We would expect Leticia to share 50% of her genetic material
with each, with her mother, father and brother. But the 50% will
look different for her parents compared to what she shared with her
brother. Can you tell which of these comparisons is with Leticia's brother?